just like with Google search
the the additional language models large
language models
you basically don't have to remember
nearly as much
just like with stack Overflow for
programming now that these language
models can generate code right there I
mean I find that I write like maybe
eighty percent ninety percent of the
code I write is as uh non-generated
first and then edited I mean so you
don't have to remember how to write
specifics of different functions oh
that's great and it's also it's not just
the the specific
coding I mean in the in the context of
uh of a large company like this I think
before an engineer can sit down to code
they first need to
figure out all of the libraries and
dependencies that you know tens of
thousands of people have written before
them and
um you know one of the things that I'm
excited about that we're working on is
it's not just um you know tools that
help Engineers code it's tools that can
help summarize the whole knowledge base
and and help people be able to navigate
all the internal information and I think
that's
um in the experiments that I've done
with this stuff I mean that's
on the public stuff you just you know
ask ask
um
one of these models to
build you a script that does anything
and it basically already understands
what the best libraries are to do that
thing and pulls them in automatically
it's I mean I think that's super
powerful that was always I the most
annoying part of coding was that you had
to spend all this time actually figuring
out what the resources were that you
were supposed to import before you could
actually start building the thing yeah I
mean there's of course
the flip side of that I think for the
most part is positive but the flip side
is if you Outsource that thinking to an
AI model you might miss nuanced mistakes
and bugs they're good you lose the skill
to find those bugs
and those bugs might be uh the code
looks very convincingly right
but it's actually wrong in a very subtle
way
but that's that's the trade-off that we
uh
that we face as human civilization when
we build more and more powerful tools
when we stand on the shoulders of taller
and taller Giants we could do more but
then we forget how to do all the stuff
that they did
it's a it's a weird trade-off yeah I
agree I mean I think it's I think it is
very valuable in your life to be able to
do basic things too